My chest, it's,
like, burning up.
All right.
Let's go back, Vince.
Please, back.
What am I gonna do, take back
that knife I left in that guy?
And give back
a pound of 100% pure snow?
You must be
a comic, kiddo.
I don't want
to die, Vince.
Do you know what this will
bring when I break it down?
Vince!
Miserable...
Hey!
At least you got
a nice clean ambulance.
It's more than
some of us get.
We interrupt this program to bring
you a hot-off-the-wire bulletin.
Two criminals have escaped
from the maximum security prison
at San Quentin
a few hours ago.
Vincent Ryker
and William Dabner
stabbed and killed one guard, wounded
another guard and the prison physician.
They reached
the rear of the hospital,
leaped into the parked ambulance
and roared through the gate
before prison officials
could stop them.
Smart thinking, huh? We have
not been able to determine
the extent of the guards'
and Dr. Corce's injuries.
Warden Merrick has just
issued a statement to the press
that both men are desperate and
considered extremely dangerous.
"Extremely dangerous. "
Dabner is described as
5'6", 155 pounds,
blond hair, blue eyes.
Vince Ryker is 6'1",
brown curly hair
and brown eyes.
They are believed
headed south.
All the way to LA, Daddy.
Warden Merrick also warns civilians that
these men are probably heavily armed...
Heavily armed is right.
A million bucks.
Ryker and Dabner are
not to be approached.
Stay tuned for further
hot-off-the-wire details.
And now back to
soft music till dawn.
Bunch of lying cops.
Boy, thanks, mister.
Things are tough,
huh, kiddo?
It's that jailbreak. They're all
passing me up. They're afraid, I guess.
I could be one of them cons
dressed up like a sailor.
Well, maybe you are.
How do I know?
Want me to get out?
Nah, I'll take a chance.
Hop in the back.
Sack out for a while.
Thanks a lot, Mister, uh...
Justin, Vince.
This is sure swell
of you, Vince.
Another one.
You'll have to
get out of the car.
Okay, sleeping beauty.
What time is it?
8.00.
License please.
Just your license.
I.D. Card?
Hey, this is the fourth
one of those things.
You're not the only one,
Mr. Justin.
Where're you
coming from?
Monterey. I left last night,
about midnight.
You didn't break any speed
laws, that's for sure.
I'll leave the speed stuff
up to the young kids.
What do you do?
Salesman, cosmetics.
Where do you live?
It's right there
on the registration.
I know.
624 North 8th Street,
San Diego.
Okay.
Okay, get in.
Where'd you get
picked up, sailor?
Gee, I don't know. It was
about two or three hours ago.
What's his name?
I was practically asleep
when he told me.
It's, uh, uh...
Justin! Yeah,
that's right, Justin.
I'm sorry, Mr. Justin,
I'm not very good on names.
Forget it.
How about it? I've got
a million people to see.
So have we,
Mr. Justin.
We bring you a special news
bulletin from police headquarters.
Police have just identified
one of the two bodies
found in the charred
wreckage of the ambulance
used in the daring
San Quentin escape last night.
The other body is now
listed as a John Doe.
A tri-state alarm has
been issued for Vincent Ryker.
It is suspected Ryker killed
a passing motorist
and has used the body in
his effort to confuse police.
We will continue to
interrupt our regular program
to bring you the latest
developments. Some confusion.
He's one man,
holding the lives of three
million people in his hands.
The people should
know, Mark.
What?
That Ryker is loose with a cylinder
of death that could wipe out a city?
That we don't
know where he is?
We'd start a
first-class panic.
We could evacuate.
Excuse me, Lieutenant.
Yeah?
Will there be
anything else, sir?
No, you'd better go down to
traffic, see if anything's come in.
Yes, sir.
Where could we put
three million people,
with no guarantee that Ryker wouldn't
be right in the middle of them,
no matter where
we send them?
June?
Oh, Vince.
Vince, it's been such
a long time. So long.
Could have been longer.
I didn't want you
out this way.
When I heard...
Not this way.
What difference does it make? I'm
out. That's what counts, isn't it?
That counts most.
Let me take
a look at you.
You haven't changed.
You have changed.
The first year you take it
and the second year you change,
then you get out.
Not this way.
What difference does it make?
I'm out the right way.
Could you have
waited eight years?
I'd have waited.
For what, an ex-con?
Do you know the difference
between a con and an ex-con?
Well, there isn't any.
You're just dead meat,
dishwashing the rest of your life.
And what are you now?
I'm plenty,
because I've got plenty.
Enough so you won't ever
have to work and worry again.
I told you, Vince,
I don't want that much.
Darling, I told
you before...
But, baby,
you've got it.
We can go places,
live big.
Yes, Vince.
What do you think I am, some
kind of animal or something?
Don't you think I know what's
good in life and what's bad?
I know what's good.
So do you, and you
want it as bad as I do.
Whatever you say, Vince.
I'm not an animal.
I'm a person. I want
things, especially you.
Excuse me.
I'm Dr. John Wallace. I'm looking
for Lieutenant Mark Richards.
Yes, Doctor, they're
expecting you in here.
Thank you.
Dr. Wallace.
Am I glad to see you.
You sounded as if you
might be over the phone.
Chief Jensen,
this is Dr Wallace,
of the Air Pollution
Control District.
Glad to see you, Doctor.
Glad to know you, sir.
He's the radiological
coordinator.
I'm going to give it
to you fast, Doctor.
Last night, a convict by the name of
Vince Ryker escaped from San Quentin,
after stealing what he believes
to contain a pound of pure heroin.
What do you
want with me?
It doesn't
contain heroin.
It contains cobalt-60
in granular form.
Cobalt-60?
Just how powerful
is it, Doctor?
Well, it's easily
dissipated and spread.
And in granular form it's the
most deadly thing in existence.
Contamination begins
almost immediately.
Within 84 hours,
you're dead.
We know that,
Doctor.
Is it in
a lead casing?
No, it's in
a steel cylinder.
It's being used under
controlled volunteer experiments
at the prison hospital.
Steel is worthless
against those rays.
What if this Ryker
opens it?
We're just praying
that he doesn't.
If other people are
exposed to the cylinder,
they'll become contaminated too,
even if Ryker doesn't open it.
That's what we're
worried about.
How big is the cylinder?
Vince, where did you
get all the makeup?
I got it from
a friend of mine.
We sort of changed
identities for a while.
I'll be right out, baby.
Mmm-mmm, you stay
there a minute.
I want to look
beautiful for you.
Two years, Vince. I want
you to think me beautiful.
What are you doing?
Nothing.
Come here.
I'm gonna make
this night last.
The police are gonna pick
you up, you know that?
I know.
We won't be seeing
each other for a while.
Vince, can't we?
We can't. They'll be watching
you. They know about us.
Won't be long, will it?
Well, as quick as
I can make it.
Then I come back
and I'll have a bundle,
and you and I can go away and
live somewhere as long as we want.
Vince, I love you so.
I've waited...
...so long.
He's got to be
in the city by now.
What good are roadblocks if
we don't know what to look for?
There's no protection
against it?
Yes, there is.
Line up every man,
woman and child
and issue them a lead
suit and a Geiger counter.
Mark, that man
must be found...
How many men in your
radiological unit?
About 25.
That you can trust
to be silent?
They've all been trained in
panic control. They won't talk.
The cobalt is probably
in a confined space.
It won't be easy to detect
from any great distance.
Yeah, that Ryker's got
all the luck on his side.
All right, Doctor, brief
your men and send them out.
Washington had better
be notified, sir.
Washington, DC.
It's urgent, please.
I'll be in my office.
Yes, Hank?
Excuse me, Lieutenant, but
I have three of them waiting,
including the girlfriend.
Only three?
Two of them are in stir back
east and one of them's dead.
The others are transient,
address unknown.
Ryker never had
any friends.
Well, let's get to it.
Where's Ryker?
I don't know.
I didn't know anything
two years ago,
and I don't know
anything now.
Miss Marlowe,
we want Ryker, fast.
I think you'd
want to help.
I told you,
I don't know where he is.
But you were
very close.
Very close.
Close enough that he confided in
you, introduced you to his friends.
Vince is the strong,
silent type,
and if he had any friends
he never brought them around.
We liked to be alone.
All right, Miss Marlowe,
you can go.
Thank you very much.
Keep yourself available.
Would you like the key
to my apartment?
That won't be necessary.
But I suggest that if Ryker contacts
you, you let us know immediately.
I will. Then you can all come
over and we'll have a party.
You have a lot of answers,
miss. I'll tell you a few.
You help Ryker,
you become an accessory.
Every crime he commits,
you commit.
Whenever he goes back to the
penitentiary, you go along with him.
You can go.
We put a stakeout
on her, Lieutenant.
I don't want her to know
that. Get Hallon in here.
Good morning,
Lieutenant.
Mr. Crown.
Look, Lieutenant,
I know why I'm here.
So Ryker worked for me
a couple of months.
Ten.
I told you that
at the trial.
Am I a marked man just
because I give a guy a job?
A man who was a pusher,
and had a criminal record
as long as your arm.
Well, that's
the whole story.
I want to co-operate,
believe me, but...
Mr. Crown, if Ryker
contacts you,
you could be signing
your own death warrant.
I've got nothing.
Ryker is dangerous.
If he isn't caught soon, he
might become desperate, deadly.
Sure, I believe you, Lieutenant,
but why should he contact me?
You, uh... You received
a letter from him,
February the 4th,
last year.
Oh, yeah, yeah,
yeah, I remember.
It was something like,
"I'm not getting any letters"
and what a swell guy I am,
you know
the sort of thing.
Did you answer it?
Well, to tell you the truth,
Lieutenant, I don't remember.
Are you sure?
Look, Lieutenant,
I got a thousand things
to think about in a year.
Owning an exclusive
shoe store sounds fine,
but it takes
a lot of work to keep it.
Unless something's important,
I don't remember it.
Did any of his friends
ever contact you?
Just his girl, once.
The reason I remember
her is because
once you've seen her,
you've seen her.
All right. Thanks a lot,
Mr. Crown. You can go.
Sure.
I'm sorry I couldn't help you any more.
I would if I could,
believe me.
If Ryker contacts you, you
let us know immediately.
Believe me.
Now ain't
he the little dandy.
Do you know him?
Huh?
I said,
do you know him?
No, no, I, uh...
I don't know him.
Sit down, Hallon.
Spit out the gum,
Hallon.
Spit out
the gum, Hallon.
Hallon...
Give me Crestview
2-4-5-9-9, please.
Yes, sir.
Good evening, Crown's.
Eddie? Vince.
You must have
the wrong number.
Look, don't get cute, Eddie.
I'm in no mood.
Do you know
what's going on?
I know what's going on,
but you don't, not yet.
Listen to me...
Hello, Eddie?
Eddie?
What's up?
All right, honey, sure.
Cops, huh?
No. No, no, I'm not mad.
Uh, listen,
hold on a minute.
Jeannie?
Yes, Mr. Crown?
I'll take this
in my office.
Take care of your customer,
sweetheart.
I'll hang up for you.
That's all right.
Thank you.
Is there something
I can do for you?
You sure make it hard to say no, honey.
But Mr. Crown will
take care of me.
Get out of here.
Now, baby,
I'm just smart enough
to know cops are smart.
So if Crown was called in, it's 'cause
the cops figure Vince might contact him.
Why?
Because they know
something I don't.
What? I don't know.
But cops are smart,
so I'll have to
go along with them.
Smart?
I've always been a soft
touch for you, Pete.
That's just ended.
Okay, Mr. Crown.
Ah, Mr. Parker,
I won't have you leaving this
establishment dissatisfied, believe me.
I don't know anything
about Ryker. Why should I?
And you shouldn't
be here.
The cops are probably
watching both of us right now,
putting two and two together
like you're trying to do.
Why don't you be smart
and forget it?
How about a pair of
alligator shoes?
With my compliments.
We know he's here
somewhere, but where?
We haven't any leads.
We don't even know
what identity he's using.
A stakeout on a girl's
apartment and a couple of bars
in 600 square miles.
I tell you, Mark,
it's ridiculous.
It's
only been 46 hours.
Forty-six years, Mark.
The people have a right
to know what's facing them.
They won't know who's facing
them any more than we do.
Everyone will be
under suspicion.
The phone lines will be
jammed with false reports.
The people will be driven
to it, they'll be scared,
just like we are.
The only difference is,
we get paid not to show it.
Huh. I don't think
we're being fair.
They might take it more
calmly then we think.
Look at the English
during the Blitz.
They knew where the
bombs were coming from.
Well, we could have the mayor
go on television and radio
and explain it
carefully and calmly.
Ryker might have
that thing open right now.
I don't think so.
Why not?
If it were floating, we
would have detected it by now.
He's gonna need
some kind of tools, too.
But as for telling
the people,
it's an alternative we wouldn't
choose, but it's one we've got.
You could tell them it won't
wipe out the whole city.
There's not enough of it.
It's not a bomb. However,
it will contaminate entire
farms, milk, butter, eggs,
get carried into markets
on meat and produce,
into theaters
and restaurants,
get carried around by people on
their clothes, on their shoes,
on insects and birds,
and on children.
Then you'll have to describe
the symptoms to watch out for.
Hoarse coughing, heavy
sweat, horrible retching.
Then the blood begins to
break down, then the cells.
If you merely touch your skin, the
watered blood just oozes out of your pores.
Finally,
you hemorrhage internally.
Blood fills the lungs.
I doubt if anyone can explain
that calmly to three million people
without touching off
the worst panic in history.
Yes?
Oh, it's for you, Doctor.
Oh, fine, Tony.
Now begin your cross section about four
or five blocks from your original point.
Yes, fine.
Can we have
another 24 hours?
Yes.
What about Ryker's
condition?
It all depends how quickly
he's become affected.
In some cases, it's only
a matter of a few hours.
He could be coughing
and perspiring right now.
Notify all hospitals and
emergency medical centers
to report all cases of nausea and
upset stomach due to unknown causes.
The same thing applies to all
doctors' answering services.
Yes, sir.
Open it up!
Who is it?
I've been out there for
30 minutes making sure.
I told you today, I'm clean. The cops
still don't know a thing about me.
Oh, yeah? Well, June's
place is staked out,
and so are two other joints
I used to hang out in.
What makes you so sure?
What's the matter with you?
Have you gone nuts?
I spent over two years
up in the joint.
I went through a lot
of cops to get here.
They still don't even
know who that stiff is.
So you've been lucky.
Don't push it.
Those clothes you're wearing look like
they were made by a hopped-up tailor.
They're even pulling cops out
of retirement to look for you.
I've been over
this block 20 times,
followed my phone line for seven
blocks, that's what makes me sure.
Hmm. You sound great.
Have some coffee and
a sandwich, roast beef.
I've waited so long to eat,
now I'm not even hungry.
Clothes are
in the suitcase,
with the hammer
and the chisel.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
I've just been sweating and drinking
and sweating and
drinking some more.
You got a drink?
No.
I should've
stopped for one.
And expose yourself more?
That
would've been dumb.
Look, knock off this
"nuts" and "dumb" stuff.
You're not talking
to some punk.
I'm the guy that made
you a lot of dough.
All right, Vince.
If you want to play big shot,
play it with somebody else.
One word from me and
you're out of business.
Look, who's hiding you?
Taking care of you?
And when they wanted to find out who
supplied me, who told them to take a walk?
Come on big with other
people, but not with me.
Look, Vince, I got
no argument with you.
Great.
Get yourself a pencil and paper
and I'll hand you a half million.
Look, Vince,
this is no time to...
Oh, right now that feels
better than anything.
You ready?
All right.
One pound of snow,
440 grains
to the ounce.
We cut it.
Where'd you get
the stuff?
They're conducting some
secret junky tests up at Q.
Huh. Does that
hand you a laugh?
There's no secrets
where 3,500 cons live.
Boy, I feel rotten.
I just figured out why the
cops haven't mentioned this.
They could follow
a peddler right to you.
Believe me, that's it.
I knew that yesterday.
Yeah, but if they get into a bind about
not finding you, they will release it.
So what?
You know a junkie who can't
smell a fix 100 miles away?
Look, Vince, in 24 hours I can have
you in Miami, then over to Cuba.
Sun, ocean, casinos, just
taking it easy. Sound good?
Who buys in Cuba?
Look, when the law finally gets
around to realizing that you're gone,
they have to figure that
the stuff is gone too.
But it's here with me.
Things quiet down,
get tucked away in the files,
and we've got a million.
Well, I don't buy
the Cuba bit.
Look, this stays, I stay, and
you get rid of it when I say so.
Vince? It's Pete Hallon.
Then he did...
What?
He was in the store
when you called.
He could have
told the cops.
Well, if he did, I want him in here now.
You alone, Pete?
You're kidding.
Well, look,
I'll open the door
and you put your arm
in, real easy.
Vince! My arm!
Now, the truth,
are you alone?
Oh, Vince!
Please! I swear! Please!
Things are rough
all over.
How did you
know I was here?
Well I... I've been
waiting for you, Vince boy.
You can use me, Vince. It's big enough.
Rabbit Ears Pete.
Well, look, make yourself
at home. Have some coffee.
Twenty-five grand,
no more.
On my word.
Where did you
learn this one, Vince?
I got a few.
You better burn
those clothes.
Vince, it's dangerous for
you to stay around here.
I'll work on it
here tomorrow.
Patrol 32.
Patrol 32, would you contact
Long Beach Police Department?
Reading negative.
Patrol 23.
Patrol 23,
code seven, 1300 block,
West Pacific Coast Highway.
Patrol 23.
Reading negative.
Patrol 18.
Patrol 18. Location,
Four, Baker, Queen, Four.
Reading, 10, Mike, roger.
Patrol 18,
will you repeat?
Patrol 18. Location,
Four, Baker, Queen, Four.
Reading, 10, Mike, roger.
Patrol 18, 10-4.
Unit 32 to headquarters.
Put me through
to Dr. Wallace.
Wallace.
District five, covered.
No results.
Oh, okay, Timmons, you'd better
start making another round right away.
Over.
Uh...
Where's the chief?
You want me
to wake him up?
No, I haven't got
anything to tell him.
I don't know...
Maybe our directives
are all wrong.
We said, "From unknown
causes only. "
Every report of sickness
has been from overeating,
overdrinking,
or intestinal flu.
Yes, Wallace. No, no, Tony, nothing yet.
Chief, I would have
awakened you, but...
I wasn't sleeping.
If Ryker isn't in custody in 24
hours, I'm notifying the mayor.
Bill, you can't...
That's my decision, Mark.
Not a minute longer.
You think I like it? I'm
praying it won't be necessary.
We have to risk a panic
in order to be prepared.
Unit 32 to headquarters.
The last complete report
coming in over an hour ago.
Well, at least he hasn't
opened the cylinder yet.
It's almost 60 hours, John.
Won't that make it
easier to detect?
Not if it's in a confined
space. If Ryker...
Jensen. Timmons?
That's my man.
The devil with roentgens. Where?
Fine.
Don't let anyone
touch that car.
Doctor.
Wallace.
5100 block,
the Palm Drive.
A car with
a dead man in it.
Ryker?
Could be.
He didn't die
of radiation.
He was murdered.
Well, then
someone must...
Got there first and now
has the cobalt. Let's go.
Have a car ready
for Lieutenant Richards.
Have all units in the Palm
Drive area proceed there at once.
Talk to a man named Timmons
until Lieutenant Richards
gets there. Yes, sir.
Have an ambulance and tow
truck proceed to the same area.
It's still holding over
200 points there, Doctor.
Say, this guy's been yapping about a hot
car with Ryker dead inside, Lieutenant.
That's right, Sergeant.
But that ain't Ryker
in there, Lieutenant.
It's gotten into
the metal, John.
Pete Hallon! Had a
chance to go through it?
It's not in there, Lieutenant.
It would have registered.
Say, what's this all
about, Lieutenant?
Never mind, Sergeant.
Let these boys handle it.
Just keep these
people moving.
That car's been completely stripped,
too. Registration, license plates.
There's not even an old matchbook
cover in there, Lieutenant.
Not all, Timmons. Raise that
hood, get the motor number.
This may be Ryker's
big mistake, John.
Let's just hope we have
time to take advantage of it.
Unit one to unit two.
Go ahead, Mark.
Pete Hallon found dead
in an unidentified car.
Hallon? What about
the other thing?
It's gone. Suspect this
is the missing car.
Getting the... Oh,
here's the engine number.
L- H-V-1-3-0-2-6-5-4-5-7-A.
Repeat.
Good, Mark,
I'll get to it myself.
Out.
At least that
still leaves Ryker.
Oh, man, am I sick.
Here's a special bulletin
from police headquarters.
A little more than
an hour ago,
Police discovered
the body of Pete Hallon,
a petty hoodlum and former
acquaintance of Vincent Ryker.
The body was found
in a car believed to be
the one stolen by Ryker
during his daring escape
from San Quentin
three days ago.
A note of mystery was added as newsmen
reported the presence of some men
with strange instruments who were carefully
handling the car and Hallon's body.
Chief of Police Jensen
was unavailable for comment.
Yeah?
I just heard, Vince.
What are you trying to do?
Look, Eddie,
don't cry over bums.
Well, you didn't
have to kill him.
Vince, you'll have
to get out of town.
Don't start that again.
Do you know what
you've done? The cops...
Cops! Cops! Look, I'm sick
of hearing about cops.
This cold is killing me,
my nose is even bleeding.
Cold! Nosebleed!
Listen to me, Vince...
Shut up, will you?
Look, I don't have any wheels, so...
So why don't you pick me up in a half hour,
and get me some penicillin or something.
That wouldn't be very smart,
my picking you up, I mean.
Look, what're you trying
to pull, Eddie?
Use your head, Vince.
We're both in this.
I'm the only chance we've got
to keep out of it. Believe me.
Eddie, I told you that I...
Listen to me!
The car, the car's
got to get tabbed.
I stripped the car.
The motor number, it can
be traced through the...
DMV doesn't have a record
of it here, Lieutenant.
Ah, naturally.
Call Sacramento.
Ask them to relay
the information directly
to the police of the resident
city and have them contact us.
That'll save
a little time.
Yes, sir.
Oh!
So I like beautiful
things.
Thank you.
Jeannie, be the boss for a
while. I'll be back about 2.30.
Send out another one.
No, I'm sorry. Lieutenant
Richards has no comment.
Yes? Oh, I'm sorry.
You'll have to get that
information from the chief's office.
Right. And I've got it.
Hank, check the reports
from General Hospital.
Yes, sir.
Still the same?
Yeah.
I want all of Hallon's clothes
and effects immediately.
Still the same.
Nothing new
on this end either.
Well, this is
Hallon's stuff.
The clothes had
a very low count.
But by the nail head
of these shoes,
we figure he was
exposed about an hour.
Oh! Yes, I think
we have this style.
I'll check in the back.
You look...
Sick? You make me sick,
Eddie. Where've you been?
You're... Getting
excited about nothing.
Just like you when you glom onto
this, huh? Where've you been?
Getting a suit altered.
Shirt, socks, the works.
Ticket to Miami.
You leave at 11.00 tonight.
You'd like
that, wouldn't you?
You'd really like that.
You'd like to handle
this too, huh?
Well, I'm going to stay,
whether you like it or not.
Look, Vince, I've been
trying to get along with you.
It's an easy ride
for a half a million.
That stuff is dead
in this town.
Nobody'll touch
you but me.
And you know it.
The dumbest thing
you did was to kill Pete.
The cops will be questioning
everybody who knew him.
It isn't like you.
You're a lone wolf.
He was a leech,
everybody knew him.
He could have
told anybody.
That's your word.
Yes, it's my word,
and the only one
you've got.
I've got the key
to your freedom.
You better slow down.
No, Vince,
you slow down.
And until you do,
I do nothing for you.
What do you mean by that?
You're the big shot.
I've got the experience.
Think about it.
I just did.
Lieutenant Richards.
What? Great! Hold it!
Get me a car.
Uh, take this down. Yeah?
Yellow Cab Garage.
Cab number 3-0-4-5.
All right, wait there.
John, a hot cab.
Hank, check
this stuff out.
Shirt.
Shoes.
Genuine alligator.
Look, how long are you
gonna keep the cab tied up?
As long as necessary,
Mr. Millikin.
I'll see that you get
a receipt for it.
Oh, certainly, certainly.
Ah, uh-huh,
I told you.
Fifty or sixty pick-ups,
at least.
I'll have to keep this.
Well, I have to have it
back, you know, our record...
I'll see that
you get it back.
Yes?
I've just talked
to the driver, Sam.
He's a little confused
but on his way to the lab.
The other driver that we got
has nothing to worry about.
Hmm.
Hollywood Garage.
Yeah, right here.
Oh, thanks. Richards.
Yes, Hank?
You stay right there.
Notify Chief Jensen.
Thanks. Ryker's not
smart. We're just stupid.
Where's the manager?
Get everyone out!
Watch this alley!
Mark, this room
is burning up.
That's Ryker's
work, all right.
Call my office.
What?
Somebody's
murdered...
Just a minute.
Call my office, tell Sergeant
Johnson what we found here.
How long have you
been in this room?
I don't know.
Maybe 10 minutes.
Get this girl to a hospital right
away for a complete check-up.
Here, leave that with me.
Do you think
the cobalt's in here?
I don't know, the room
is hot enough to be.
Mark!
Yeah?
It's been here!
The shavings are
from that canister.
A dead end.
Another dead end.
Yes. Yes, yes,
I understand.
Yes, all right.
I said, all right!
Don't tell me.
Let me guess.
The mayor. Blasting the whole
thing wide open, and what a mess.
What is it? It still holds. At
1.00, he's pulling the switch.
He's going to inform the
public of what we're up against,
and he's going to make an appeal
to Ryker to give up the cobalt.
He can't! He...
"We can't jeopardize people's
lives any longer," he says.
Oh, I know what your
feelings are, Mark,
but we do know the
cobalt is in the city,
and we could get the
children out at least.
What about the panic?
Well, we'll try
to control it.
Try? You'll try...
We're going to sound
a general alert.
As soon as the sirens go
off, we'll close up the city.
We'll move in
and batten things down
and try to keep
them in line.
At 1.00, the mayor goes
on radio and television
to inform
the public and...
And to make
a plea to Ryker.
Do you think Ryker's
going to believe you?
Look, we've been
lucky so far.
The moment
he hears that report,
he's going to open up that
canister just to see what's inside.
Somebody's got to
know something.
You've tried them all. They're
all dead, except for the girl.
I'll get her in here, I'll keep
at her until I find out something.
There isn't time.
I'll keep after her
until time runs out.
Here she is,
Lieutenant.
I don't know why you've
brought me down here again.
But I don't like it
and I don't like you.
Hank.
Won't you sit down?
I'm not going to
be here that long.
Where's Ryker?
I don't know.
You were very good friends,
you were going to be married.
I haven't seen him.
I know you have.
You don't know anything.
I haven't seen him,
can't you understand?
How did you find him?
I haven't.
I've never seen him.
I don't know where he is.
Just leave me...
Just leave me alone.
We'd better get this girl to
the hospital right away, Mark.
Hank, emergency.
Mr. Justin!
What's going on in there?
Go away.
Are you drunk
or something?
Well, you've got this room
in a fine state!
You get out.
Look at that!
You'll pay for it.
I'll see to that!
You get out.
Going around
breaking up things!
You ought to be
ashamed of yourself!
You get out, or I'll
kill you, you old witch.
Dr. Wallace?
Yes. Dr. Perrin?
Yes.
Lieutenant Richards.
How do you do?
Is it what we thought?
Oh, yes. It's
a very high count.
That girl is
in serious condition.
I see. Well, remember, Doctor,
this is in strict confidence.
Oh, yes, of course.
Do you know
what this is?
It's a Geiger counter.
That clicking means that you
have radioactive poisoning.
I just fainted.
Oh...
You're a very
sick girl.
What do you mean?
I'm not sick.
Yes, you are.
Miss Marlowe, you have
radioactive poisoning.
Ryker thinks he has
heroin in that canister.
But it isn't heroin.
It's radioactive cobalt-60,
and it's killing him. Do you
understand? It's killing him.
No, you're lying...
You're a very sick
girl, but Ryker is dying.
If we get to him soon enough,
there's a chance we can save him.
A slim chance,
but a chance.
To throw him
back into prison?
Look, I don't know
how much you love him,
but even prison is
better than death.
He's here, all right.
We can't stay in here longer
than a couple of minutes, Mark.
He's gone!
Get everybody
out of here.
I don't want anyone near.
Call for more units,
I want this whole
area roped off.
HDQ to all units.
You are instructed
not to approach suspect
until the arrival
of proper personnel.
Unit 11 to HDQ. Have
received instructions. Over.
Coffee.
Yeah, yeah, sure.
That'll be a dime.
Hey, what's the matter?
You sick or something?
We interrupt this program to
bring you a special broadcast
from Mayor Benjamin Garrett.
Ladies and gentlemen,
His Honor, Mayor Garrett.
My fellow citizens... Those
guys, they can talk anytime.
It is my unhappy duty
to inform you
of a grave and immediate
crisis in our city.
I ask you not to be alarmed. Only by our
being calm can we avert a possible disaster.
A few days ago, a metal container
was stolen from the prison hospital
at San Quentin. Say, have you
been drinking or something?
Mind your own business.
This cylinder was believed to
contain a large supply of heroin.
Instead, it actually contains
a substance known as cobalt-60,
a highly
radioactive material.
Cobalt-60 is one of the most
dangerous elements in existence.
Look, fella, I don't want any
sick or drunk people around here.
Maybe I'd better call
an ambulance, huh?
He is a dying man
with no hope...
Fella, please,
why don't you go, huh?
Shut up!
I beg him not only
to save his own life
but the thousands of other lives
that can become fatally contaminated
if the canister is opened and
the cobalt allowed to escape.
Now, please listen to me. The
canister does not contain heroin.
It is certain death unless
you give it up right now.
No, it's worth a million!
Vince Ryker, I beg you to do as
I ask. To all of you listening...
It's a lie!
It's worth a million.
...At desperate speed
to bring Ryker to justice,
and already Civil Defense units are
preparing to evacuate all children
in the event Ryker
succeeds in eluding the...
Hold it!
You're
finished, Ryker.
No! It's not that stuff.
It's worth a million.
It's not even worth
your life. Give it to me.
There's still a chance
to pull you through.
Lying...
Come on,
I want to go home.